وللحرب في اوكرانيا تابعات جما منها
الداخليه واخرى خارجيه الجديد تقارير
تتحدث ان حرب اوكرانيا ساهمت بزياده
مبيعات الاسلحه عالميه هيئه لمراقبه
مبيعات الاسلحه الدوليه اشارت الى ان
مبيعات الاسلحه العالميه زادت بنحو اثنين
في المئه في عام 21 وهو العام السابع على
التوالي من الزياده واضافت الهيئه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا ادت الى زياده الطلب
على الاسلحه هذا العام لكن الصراع قد يؤدي
ايضا الى تحدي العرض لاسباب ليس اقلها ان
روسيا مورد الرئيسي للمواد الخام
المستخدمه في انتاج الاسلحه
السلام قال ان ذلك قد يعطل الجهود في
الولايات المتحده واوروبا لتعزيز قوتهما
المسلحه والتجديد مخزناتهما بعد ارسال
ذخيره ومعدات اخرى بمليارات الدولارات الى
اوكرانيا
في اثناء اعلن اليوم عن تشكيل قوه اقليميه
لحفظ السلام من قبل قادتي دول غرب افريقيا
الهدف من هذه القوه التدخل ضد المتشددين
والانقلابات كالتي شهدتها المنطقه في
العامين الماضيين قرروا التشكيل القوه
الاقليميه جاء بعد رصد مراقبين مكمنا
للخطر يتمثلوا في سوق سوداء للسلاح خلفتها
الحرب في اوكرانيا تستفيد منها الجماعات
الارهابيه في افريقيا لا سيما في منطقه
الساحل التي تمتلك منافذ اوروبا سابقا
اعربت قوى الغربيه عن مخاوفها من احتمال
التسرب السلاح الذي يتم ضخمه الى اوكرانيا
الى عصابات التهريب ومن ثم الى عصابات
اجراميه وحركات ارهابيه
لصحيفه الفرنسيه فان العواصمه الغربيه
تشعر بالقلق من احتمالات تهريب بعض
الاسلحه الى قوى اخرى غير الجيش الاوكراني
ومن بين تلك الاسلحه الصواريخ